we're doing Kavalier and clay that was
my see I know I'm out of time but I have
to ask this is that's what I'm I love
that book just look and I think that
that book could never be a movie I don't
know if you're making it as a movie I
know how it works but as a series I
think that could be amazing and Michael
and his wife I yell it together they're
writing the whole thing and it is not a
movie and you know we the two of them
and outskirts banana-like were producing
it with them have sat around and you
know got to do that thing that you want
to do with one of your favorite novels
with the author in the room which is
good on what did he do and how do you
any super fun how close is that to
getting a green light and do you
envision it as like a six eight ten
episode limited series or something that
could continue I am NOT going to I have
no idea how green lights work in
television I know that Michael and I are
writing so yeah the number of it and
when I say that I mean that different
depending on different deal structures
two scripts can trigger at 10 scripts
and Renault scripts can trigger an actor
to do it so I don't know what them the
constructor that is simply because right
now they're writing and that comes first
I I do know how long it is and again I'm
not going to tell only because it's not
me I feel like it's not actually mine to
share like it's theirs to share but I
think that they are going to give it the
breath it deserves